[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who's like captain america
because i've always got shields behind
me and
and that's because i'm from a town
called south shields in england
so a bit about me there anyway you don't
care about that what you're here for is
to learn
everything you need to know about madame
hydra and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the
character's origins in the comics
and a vanity fair article that teases
where she will be going in the future
we're also going to be giving our
theories on why she could be forming the
thunderbolts and all the dark avengers
due to what we know about the marvel
universe full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen episode 5 of falcon in the
winter soldier
and don't want anything ruined then i
recommend that you turn off now
smash the thumbs up button if you enjoy
it and don't forget to subscribe for
videos like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into who
madame hydra is okay so there are
actually two people who've adopted the
moniker madame hydra
in the comic books firstly is ophelia
sarkisian
who first appeared in captain america
110.
a hungarian orphan she was taken under
hydra's wing
and after being put through the
organization's brutal training
she rose through the ranks and gained a
position as one of its top leaders
however she eventually left the group
and joined the serpent society
which is where she killed its leader
viper and took his name
now the other version of the character
that we meet in the show is called
contessa valentina allegra de la
fontaine
or val for short just just don't tell
her even thought that
now both she and her family were sleeper
agents for the group leviathan
and they were placed inside an
anti-communism movement here they caught
the eye of dum dum duggin
who was completely unaware that they
were actually performing
special operations for the group val
ended up becoming a shield agent
and during her training she came face to
face with nick fury
valentina actually bested him in
hand-to-hand combat
and he was like well this is totally
normal from a person in training
let's give her lots of power and
authority she ended up becoming a
leading member of shield
kind of person who has clearance level
10 and stuff
and she was sent on several missions the
contessa was successful
in a hell of a lot of them and she even
ended up starting a relationship with
nick fury
val actually drove a wedge between him
and captain america
as she flirted with the latter off and
on and this angered nick
it even led to the two facing off
against each other because
if cap is willing to travel through time
just to get a girl
then you know the man will do whatever
he can to steal yours
r.i.p peggy's husband now the contessa
gained more and more power over the
years
and she secretly joined hydra which is
where she took the madame mantle
val was pretty much a triple agent at
this point is it
i don't know but she was working for a
lot of people and she betrayed hydra to
her masters leviathan
the aforementioned viper almost died
during one of their many battles
and it led to an all-out war between
several shadowy factions
eventually she was discovered and
unearthed as a sleeper agent within
shield
and the character was sent to prison to
spend the rest of her days behind bars
now as for the show version we know
she's out in the wild
and according to the wiki for black
widow she will be appearing in that
movie too
shout outs to superhero nexus for
sending me that bit of info
along with a vanity fair article that
opens up a lot about where the character
could be going in the future
now the article starts off by saying
that this is one of the better kept
secrets in marvel history
that's definitely true and i spent the
last week trying to narrow down who the
actress could be
and settled on it being a blonde woman
which as we saw was completely right
but paul it wasn't completely right i
said
now julia louis dreyfus is an 11 time
emmy-winning actress
and she will be playing the contessa
going forward beep co-star tony hale has
apparently known for a long time
and he actually told vanity fair selena
was so atrocious
but then you loved her at the same time
i think that makes a really good disney
villain
we now know that they meant marvel but
hey it all makes sense
and as always it's all connected now the
article goes under theorize that she
might actually be the power broker
in the finale it's definitely something
that's a possibility
and the show could be setting it up to
make us think that sharon carter is when
it's really valve behind it all
madame hydra frequented mad rapport in
the comics and thus
she could be the power broker all along
she clearly has a lot of things going on
and might even be keeping her eyes on
walker as a way to get the highly
coveted serum from him
we know through isaiah bradley that it
can be replicated once it's taken from
someone's blood
and thus it does make a lot of sense
that she would be able to get it from
his cells
now the article goes under theorize that
because she was originally a russian
sleeper agent
that she may be part of black widow's
red room training program
and that this is how she'll show up in
the film however it's interesting that
she's going around recruiting people
much like nick fury especially because
of their relationship in the comics
she's very much in opposite to that in
the latest entry of falcon in the winter
soldier
and she could turn up at the end of
widow potentially taking elena bulova
in the comics val was also part of a
group known as the femme force
which had sharon carter as a leader so
the pieces are definitely in place to
tie
everything together should they ever
need to either way it seems like they're
setting her up to be a very influential
character going forward
and that she will likely be someone i
think who brings together either the
thunderbolts
or the dark avengers in the most recent
episode
zemo was sent to the raft which was a
prison that we saw in civil war
overseen by general ross he would go on
to form the thunderbolts
which is sort of an avengers group of
anti-heroes kevin feige has stated that
the abomination will to be coming back
at some point
and that he is currently situated at the
raft too
this it makes a lot of sense that ross
would be bringing the criminals together
under that roof
in order to form a brand new team now
this is all just me theorizing at the
moment
but with the inclusion of louis dreyfus
i do feel that
almost everything is adding up for us to
see the formation of a new team
it seems weird that they would even
bring a character and actor in of this
statue that was walking around
recruiting people
if it wasn't for something much bigger
so expect to see these blank cards
dotted throughout the mcu
and whilst the avengers are out of
action there is room for new people to
come in and take control
the thunderbolt lineup is starting to
slot into place and when you have
characters like us
agent zemo abomination taskmaster
and elena belova all waiting at the
sidelines
then you can bet that there are plans
for them in the future there's also the
possibility of her being a scroll
in secret invasion and i'll i'll stop
before this gets to mephisto
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the character and what you
want to see
happen in the mcu going forward comment
below and let me know and as a thank you
for interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize during the 30th of
april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
the links to our socials are also in the
description and you can support the
channel by clicking the join button and
as a thank you you get videos like this
early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out operation of
episode 5 which will be linked on screen
right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom and offered up our
theories
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been poor i see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you